[Musique]
je
mesdames messieurs bonsoir notre invité
s'appelle anicia berton bonsoir alors
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas annie
chaberton alors vous êtes militante
écologiste
et pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
anicia berton mais regardez qui initia
berton en quelques secondes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non je ne suis pas dans une optique
politique politicienne pour moi il est
impératif de hors jeu soit représenté
que mon identité soit représentée donc
c'est pour moi c'est normal de valoriser
mon drapeau mon anglais nous mettez
justement pour nous revendiquer identité
nous nous ces nations matinik et donc
nous mettait justement pour nous pour
nous valoriser patrie est ma patte
matinik adam fin adam société a nui et
là c'est bien mais si bon dié guerrier
vigué du but
aniche à blaton quand vous regardez ces
images qu est ce que vous vous dites et
bien c'est beaucoup de salons chemin le
chemin parcouru pour pour des causes
justes et nobles pour la cause
martiniquaise pour l'humain les valeurs
humaines c'est ça qu'on ne comprend pas
trop chez vous pourquoi est-ce que vous
militez avec autant de passion
eh bien j'ai ça fait des années quand
même que je milite mais il a fallu que
je rencontre
monsieur garcin malsa absolument qui est
qui est un petit peu enfin on va dire
qui est mon mentor qui m'a mis sur la
voie de l'écologie qui m'a mise sur la
voie de l'humanité de l'histoire mon
histoire africaine et qui m'a donné
l'envi justement de me battre pour la
cause martiniquaise et pour la
reconnaissance et des valeurs de des
martiniquais mais au-delà de ça on a
vraiment l'impression que vous avez que
vous vous battez parce qu'il ya une
raison personnelle
moi quand je vous vois sur le terrain
c'est toujours avec en tout cas en
matière d'écologie c'est toujours avec
une forme de d'ardeur de force
intérieure on se demande mais qu'est ce
qui la pousse alors je vais vous avouer
quelque chose peut-être que vont tout le
monde c'est clair que tout le monde peut
au courant c'est que j'ai eu un cancer
du sein est en fait en six ans là je
suis à mon deuxième cancer est
effectivement j'étais déjà militante
mais le fait d'être moi même victime
ça m'a donné plus envie de me battre
justement pour pour la population
martiniquaise qui en souffrance et ça
m'a donné l'envi justement de dénoncer
les corps les comportements crapuleux de
certaines personnes qui mettent nos vies
en danger
voilà et il faut dire aussi que bon j'ai
aussi grandi en france
je n'ai pas grandi ici j'ai grandi sur
la france et j'ai été à l'école
là-bas et j'ai été victime directe de du
racisme et notamment bon si on est
arrivé là bas aussi c'est parce que ma
mère a été l'une des personnes qui
étaient qui est partie par le bibendum
donc ça a créé plusieurs ça signifie en
fait ça signifie que qu'à travers toutes
ces manifestations
vous vous cherchez à protéger la
population c'est ça tout à fait j'ai
cherché à protéger la population à
conscientiser la population pour qu'elle
puisse les dangers de l'écho sur les
dangers de l'écologie sur la protection
de la mangrove la protection de même
parce qu'on fait tous partie d'un
écosystème qui s'emboîtent
donc si on ne protège pas la nature nous
mêmes envies de la nature
donc on est obligé de protéger la nature
pour se protéger soi même et si la
nature est pollué si elle est détruite
nous mêmes on meurt parce qu'on ne peut
pas les sens alors danger du non respect
de l'écologie
et puis cette semaine vous avez une
actualité également cette semaine vous
étiez entendu pendant quelques minutes
chez les gendarmes des trois idées qu
est ce qu on vous reproche alors bon je
suis une militante activiste
je n'ai jamais nié je dénonce des faits
de corruption
en martinique où des familles sont
victimes de vols de terre et où des pour
moi une vraie mafia organisée je le
répète puisque j'ai été j'ai été
convoqué pour ça parce que effectivement
je mets des preuves sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire on vous a convoqué
c'est à dire parce que vous avez des
documents on a des documents on a dit
que les familles nous nous transmettre
les documents s'agit des gens qui se
font vous dites voilà alors je vais je
vais énoncer quelques familles comme la
famille malouines gilles à la fin me
gratte la famille carole la famille
hausse tant côté des trois ilets du côté
de détroit a fait les gendarmes vous
entendu précisément parce que vous avez
des preuves que vous avez mis sur les
réseaux sociaux
j'ai mis sur les réseaux sociaux un faux
acte de naissance alors cet acte de
naissance il y en a deux le numéro 87
le premier acte de naissance c'est c'est
un juge qui fait la reconnaissance de sa
propre soeur sur l'acte de naissance
d'une des victimes en fait c'est la
famille brigitte et le juge a fait la
reconnaissance sur l'acte de naissance
de marie sorbet qui est là la grande
tente de monsieur brigitte brigitte
françois rodrigue ça signifie simplement
que vous êtes invités à obtenir un
certain nombre de preuves que vous avez
été entendu par les gendarmes pour ça
j'ai été entendu par les gendarmes pour
ça tout à fait et j'ai aussi on a
cherché à savoir quels documents en
avait on a cherché à savoir où je
prenais les informations et moi afin
bien sûr je leur ai expliqué que ce sont
les familles qui nous donnait les qui me
donne les documents et que je ne suis
pas non plus tout seul à travailler sur
ces dossiers et qu'il ya d'autres
personnes qui travaillent dessus alors
les images qu'on voit actuellement c'est
quand vous êtes sortis de la gendarmerie
des trois ilets est ce que vous êtes
menacés à ce que des fois vous êtes non
c'est clair que quand on mène ce genre
de combat on est on a des tentatives
d'intimidation ses clients que on et
invectivé sur les réseaux et même plus
encore mais vous savez quand on a choisi
de se battre pour son peuple
quand on a choisi de défendre son peuple
quand on a choisi de deux on a choisi
cette vie en fait mais on n'a pas peur
en fait on va sur le terrain et puis on
fait ce qu'on a à faire
alors vous êtes militant tasso pamart 0
chlordécone zéro pesticide
je mets mes lunettes parce que je
n'arrive pas à lire sans lunettes vous
avez fait partie de ceux qui ont déversé
des sargasses à la préfecture on a
l'impression que vous ne faites pas
confiance aux autorités pour régler les
problèmes
et à l'écologie et surtout pas confiance
à nos politiques écoutez je vais un
petit peu revenir sur l'affairé brigitte
quand les familles vont au tribunal et
qu'un juge se permet de de faire de
comment comment je peux vous expliquer
d'accepter le témoignage de personnes
qui ne sont pas encore nés
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
qui êtes né en 1900 échec vous témoigner
comme quoi vous avez connu un
propriétaire qui est né en 1801 d'accord
et le juge accepte le témoignage quand
on présente de faux documents comme par
rapport à la biomasse ou sur les
différents combat qu'on a mené
effectivement il ya il ya des défauts il
y à il y a des enfin on ne respecte pas
les lois en fait les lois ne sont pas
respectées et nos élus qui sont courants
ne disent rien en fait
c'est à dire qu'ils sont courants
puisqu'on publie sur les réseaux
qu'est-ce qu'on a des fontaines de
personnes qui viennent qui viennent voir
nos publications ne serait ce que sur ma
page anicia berthier et c'était pour
précisément dire on fait pas confiance
aux politiques et à l'état que vous avez
déverser des services à la préfecture
c'est pour dire au préfet que on nous
impose
on nous impose des choses on a une
catastrophe sanitaire et et que je
trouve qu'on trouve que effectivement
ils prennent ça à la légère alors qu'il
ya des familles qui sont danger il ya
des enfants qui sont asthmatiques
il ya des gens qui arrivent à kiki ceux
qui vont à l'hôpital
donc ce sont des sujets qui sont graves
comme le chlordécone comme la sargasse
on ne peut pas prendre ça à la légère et
en tant qu'association puisque je suis
comme aussi président de l'association
nation matnik en tant qu'association on
se doit effectivement d'aller sur le
terrain et de montrer au préfet et aux
politiciens qui sont là pour nous servir
et non se servir
qu'il faille qui travaillent pour nous
qu'il faut qu'il prenne nos vies en
considération nous sommes des humains et
je suis désolé ils ne font pas grand
chose on ne les entend pas alors
précisément vous n'êtes plus dans une
association tout à fait politique ou pas
pas politique non c'est à dire pourtant
je sentais bien que autour de vous il se
crée un mouvement vous rassembler des
jeunes oui donc toujours un jour nous il
va falloir aller le suffrage universel
alors écoutez la politique ont elles
mêmes à politique politicienne ça ne
m'intéresse pas mais quand vous militez
pour le drapeau oui le drapeau wee cc
c'est un geste politique c'est sûr parce
que on a une histoire qui qui qui vient
de là de la traite négrière d'accord
précisément les images que l'on voit
c'est le fanion de la gendarmerie tout à
fait qui a été qui sera peut-être un
jour retirer toute attente c'est pas con
ça et ça aussi c'est un de vos combats
tout à fait je vais commencer justement
par des uns des textes de loi pope
enfin je vais commencer par expliquer à
la population qui a des lois qu'on nous
impose et qu'on nous sommes sensibles
respecter la loi taubira dick
l'esclavagé est un crime contre
l'humanité c'est une loi qui a été crié
accord tout ce qui est en rapport avec
les esclavages ces parties du crime
le pavillon esclavagistes qui était sur
le mas des bateaux négriers qui faisait
partie de la marine marchande que la
france quand j'entends macron dire que
enfin excusez moi je vous donne dans le
public mais choisir que pour
l'apaisement qu'il l'enlève
je me dis que c'est c'est une vaste
blague parce que le papier un
esclavagiste faisait partie de la marine
marchande ça fait partie de leur
histoire
l'histoire de la traite négrière anicia
berton merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
trente secondes parce que là je suis
entraîneur j'adore faire alors je
voudrais dire à la population pour ceux
qui viennent qui veulent venir rejoindre
l'association nation matnik qui peuvent
nous contacter à l'adresse mail
nation matnik @ gmail point com et sur
la page facebook et l'installent g de
nation matnik nouvelle occasion de se
revoir initia berton merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
merci à vous chers téléspectateurs on se
retrouve le 11 novembre et où il
dimanche 11 novembre pour cause de
vacances de toussaint
bonnes vacances et à bientôt
[Musique]